so that opening was actually present in
the last two reps but Sean you went into
chemi
mode that one was down okay so
here my goal is just to push okay so I
keep my palms and I
push you feel that arm getting
compressed you see
okay so go ahead and we'll do that do
that pattern again and see when he does
that so I would follow follow that hole
you
see so instead you go do that go ahead
do it again and the you stop now I'm not
pushing you
see but that's
Yin and now this comes here you see
so keep going
it's coming underneath you
see so he can't learn if I don't do my
job you're trying to push what's pushing
at you right
okay and he know he can feel that you
when he stops it's cuz he felt that it's
it was too y so he you here okay and so
you felt that that's what was going to
happen Okay and then he stopped
so you should be able to
see he changing it he can feel it but
you should be able to see it like I saw
it
okay so he's trying to push what's
pushing on him it just do you I'm just
like I'm allowed to talk and then
eventually he pushes me over right on
that rep
there's that y
again so I'm not pushing my hardest
right so the Y value is relatively low
which is why he could push that over
that last time but here he goes to Yin
even this low y value is going to expose
the in space and he feels it right
there okay all right so don't push
what's pushing at you okay even even if
you could overpower it you shouldn't
okay careful you go here in the external
yield you're going to get smashed okay
so even though you're moving this way
let go here you can't you can't compress
it you see and so I can turn
it you see and then you have the
projection on this arm
okay so right now you're looking to
push or even set up a push where you're
now going to push here
okay take the pressure that's happening
you see that that pressure there find
out how to turn
it
okay and
then easy to manipulate okay so even
with a good C or a good
muscle you don't want to use those
things in isolation from sound
in geometry in this drill okay so we'll
I'll look at that pattern again you can
see how he's getting on top of it you
see so I don't want to go
up okay so I know as you're pushing
there has to be some downward yield you
see that's why that's happening every
time you
see so let's look he's sitting up higher
than me and so when he goes to push
there's a downward this do you see it
Sean okay
and so I don't try to shove up I don't
try to shove this way I have to find the
shape that goes with your downward this
that takes you into that P okay all
right so here I am and I am pushing
straight ahead you see that on you maybe
even the slide up right okay so let's
see if you do that to me no don't do the
down one you got to pretend you're
shorter than me okay yeah yes okay so
now for me to go down you see I'm
fighting you again you see so as you're
pushing up I use the up you see and then
there's that
P okay got it okay so you got to find
the shape not just push against it okay
all right let's try that let's bring
some awareness that I do have
to adapt to what you're doing
without contesting okay all right
okay so
um so with Thea's correction is just to
note there is a pattern you must take
okay you can't just push
push now here we want to know what that
pattern is okay so kind of what you're
doing is the kind of turning him let me
let me you're kind of like turning him
you
see sometimes you turn him just kind of
turn turning
him and then sometimes you just
pushed okay and what we
want is not not a
turn but a tilt so the yin hand is going
to generate some sort of tilt okay and
there's a tilt you see that it's in this
plane here but we have this plane here
so I do the same tilt and I bring it
this way you see now you're tilting
forward and you're tilting laterally
okay so the yin hand is is always going
to tilt
you in those two Dimensions
okay and then the Y hand is always going
to now cut across the
Tilt and so this is why I can't turn
you that never
happens even if I pull you and I get
that tilt there you see this hand
doesn't go and turn you more
okay and obviously I get a tilt here now
both hands are pushing do you see this
hand stopped so you must always get the
Tilt it's coming forward then through
the center
tilt see don't start doing
that this one goes this
way take the one I was doing with the
youu so you give me that that downward
this that he was giving me right and
you'll see who there's the Tilt now this
one doesn't go this way it goes that
way okay
that you're just doing that over even as
crazy as it might seem I just going to
this and then
that doing that over and
over so this hand looks like it's
pushing you see that but it's not see
okay it's keep taking you in the Tilt
okay then this hand looks like it's
going
around but it's not you
see you don't don't feel the external
try to do
[Music]
that
okay let's add
that tiled him in the
center tilt
Center there okay we're kind of putting
aside the energetics for now okay and
just working with physical part of
things all right we'll get there all
right so I have to start your tilting
there it is right there and then this
hand has to go in the center right okay
so when you get there don't push your
hand you see that okay you move the qua
from the top so you know that the qua
from the seams but there's a top to the
quaw okay and that's what you move so
you get the Tilt and then you move that
top
part you
see as opposed to here trying to shove
okay even if you get a good tilt you
shouldn't make your hand go like that
you'll you'll
qua moves your hands so here there's you
feel that not now I don't move that I
move
my
tilt okay here on my body
qu you should have
this this because you're tilted it's
this so my seams are closing and tilting
so you're over here this is the C hold
position
okay you're doing the same
thing notice how this hand doesn't go
there
W feel the
CL here here and for
forward
okay bring that in you do you you say to
upright and your hands go in and out
okay try to do
okay so I say you're at you're doing
what I want a use should do everything
up to this point okay so you have some
tilts right and then you use your
quad that's good and I use you're
getting that now okay you some tilt and
you use the CLA again
okay all right now let's pay attention
to something okay so as you're
pushing and I'm starting to turn this
thing you see
okay at a certain point mark the value
at the at the Y hand whatever you
whatever that is okay and watch How It's
going to increase you see that it's
increasing that's me moving the claw
into it
okay I do it again I'll do that same
side again you're walk you're feeling
for this hand
so there it is at that value and I move
the quaw into it you see it goes up you
see that
okay so
displacement which is your Center
falling outside your line of gravity at
some point has to be at a positive y to
the given value okay it has to be y plus
X okay so if you pay attention here is
the value you
see it's going to go soft you see that
so feel the value push okay feel that it
goes soft you see and then it it's in
ining again you see that
okay so
boom soft
increase what it is I'm going to
decrease it with the angle deviation
that's the void
aspect and then it'll increase you see
it's increasing do you see that okay so
I call this catching so there that is
I'm going to do void and I catch that
you see and now that is my projection so
before I had to
physically displace
you you see on this one I void
catch do you see that okay and it's it's
not magic it's it's y plus
X okay so not here and not keeping it at
Y and then adding
X but
y Yus X Y plus X you see that okay so
let's switch
rules okay so he's pushing
I'm not going to stay young and then
add the plus X you
pushes okay there's so you can feel it
you feel like whatever that resistance
is goes off you see but then I catch it
boom it goes back on plus what it was
before okay all
right so let's work on that
catching because he's not going to be
displaced unless I go y plus X it's a
different way of achieving it okay all
right you keep working on what you're
working on though
okay all right so and last time I
voided
externally then caught it you see okay
so on this one so feel feel the whatever
that pressure is there there okay now
let's go back when I externally
voided where did you go into into the
opening yeah into the into the opening
you see that okay what
you I want you to pay attention to the
value that's there and where your hand
is on on me
okay hands coming forward do you see
that everything so slight ention okay go
back and
grab
okay you see you feel that okay so when
I release in some
way you came in do you see that so when
I
release regardless of how don't worry
about how right now but in some way you
came forward you see that
and in this way it's it's obvious to
understanding CU I got out of the way
okay but you felt that in some way your
hand started going like that do you see
okay so as you go and I release that's
the same exact thing you see so
I'm I'm voiding just
internally and then catching catching
your y you see and then adding to the Y
okay does that make sense you feel that
okay so that's ultimately where we're
going but I really want you to feel as
you to do that right it's not that I had
to get out of your way do you see I
didn't get out of the way so even as you
do the external yields don't just go
like that you see so in other words we
know in the example that I'm giving
here's where I catch you you see but
it's not me just getting out of your way
and you came forward which is why as as
I'm moving into it you can't come
forward you see you can't come forward
you can try to bring your head forward
you see you can't come forward you can't
come forward you see can't come forward
and I'm you start to feel that I will
increase the pressure on this hand as
I'm bringing your weight onto it there
it is right there you see you add a
little claw and I'll here you go okay
so not just get out of those see this
all week your head can come forward you
see no no no you are
yielding externally but inside that is
that internal yield that you feel okay
and so you have to watch the the the
tension but then understand release is
not just get out of the way and the guy
falls through the trapo kind of thing
okay all
right it's the same exact forces we just
maybe currently don't
understand how those forces but it is
those forces okay maybe we don't
understand their
Source but they are the same forces okay